well i wanted to show you an interesting
sequence of numbers
go on
so here we go i'm going to start here
well you might notice that i'm missing
out a couple here and there 39
34 and so on most of them are here but
if you
look carefully you'll see that here
we're missing four and five
and down here we should be missing 13
and 14 23
and 22
31 and 32. well there's a supposition or
a conjecture that all of these numbers
can be written as a sum of three cubes
of integers it's probably best done by
example
if i take this number here for example
29 it means that i can write this as a
sum of three cubes of integers and in
this case it can be written as 3 cubed
plus 1 cubed so 3 cubed is 27 plus 1
cubed is 28
plus 1 cubed
is 29. so it's thought that all of the
other integers have a similar
representation and i should point out
that you are allowed to represent your
number by negative numbers as well so
you're allowed to take sums of three
cubes in which one of the or more of the
integers is a negative number what's
quite striking is that
for some of the numbers even on this
very list it's actually surprisingly
difficult to write down the solution to
the problem to illustrate what i mean we
just have to go a little bit along the
line here to this number 30 and i'm
going to need a little bit more space
but maybe you would care to hazard a
guess as to what the solution to this
problem is
is it an easy one is it a hard one
it's a hard one i should say that this
was only discovered in 1999 it was
discovered by computer it's actually
quite surprising i think so are you
ready i'm ready okay let's go i have had
to write this down
but let's go two two two zero
4 2 2
9 3 2
all cubed
plus
minus 2
1 2 8. that was a negative number this
is the negative number and there's one
more negative number here minus 283
comma
zero five nine comma nine five six
all cubed that's amazing yes it's quite
striking i think 29 was so simple and 30
was so difficult that's right so as you
carry on up the list you'll you'll find
this phenomena continuing so some
occasions where you'll be able to find
very small solutions
and then just next door to it there'll
be a number cropping up which seems to
have enormously large solutions are
there many other unsolved ones or
sadly yes i'm going to come back to
these ones
but the next eligible one is this number
and
in fact
we still don't know an answer to that
one
so we've not yet been able to find any
integers which when you sum their cubes
you get 33. search has been pretty
thorough so far they've gone up to
i think they've gone up to the numbers
of size 10 to the 14 so that's one with
14 zeros after it within that range
there are no solutions the question
people are going to have then is
i mean maybe this number doesn't belong
on the list why is the number on the
list if we haven't got a solution
that's a very good question
and there have been some attempts to
prove that this number
isn't on the list but those attempts
have failed therefore it is and it's
perfectly allowable that the first
solution might just be ginormous but
there are numbers that are off the list
let me tell you about the numbers off
the list so i'll just write them down
again so we had 4
32 so you might wonder what those
numbers have in common what have they
done wrong
well
their great crime is that they can all
be written
as nine times an integer so nine times
an integer k
plus four
or
nine times an integer k
plus five so for example four is clearly
nine times zero plus four and for
example 31 here is nine times three
which is 27 plus four so they all meet
this criteria and indeed if you write
down any number which is of this shape
nine times k plus four or nine times k
plus five
it will never be written as a sum of
three cubes and that's something that we
can actually prove i mean what's going
on here we're looking at equations of
this shape so for example a cubed plus b
cubed plus c cubed
equal to
so for example 33.
so this is an example of what's called a
diaphantine equation and this is a very
central topic in number theory it's been
studied i would say for lots of years so
they're named after someone called
diaphantus who lived in about 250 a.d a
greek
but
thinking about problems like this goes
back even further some 4 000 years to
the babylonians but the question is if
you have a polynomial equation like this
can you first of all decide whether it
has solutions and integers that's what
we're trying to do in this special case
if it does have solutions you could even
ask how many are there are there
infinitely many or just
you know just a handful and if there are
infinitely many can you describe their
frequency in some sense and this is a
sort of area of research that i'm i'm
actively engaged with so we do not have
a proof that this has solutions in
integers it is conjectured that this has
solutions in integers all that we can
hope to do at the moment is just use a
computer and try and find them this is
not something that can ever be proven by
brute force because there's always
another number isn't there absolutely
yes absolutely so i just wanted to go
back to the first number of the list
that we had up here actually number one
you know we're not going to have to
spend too much time
scratching our heads to come up with a
solution to this one
right we could take
you will never guess
one cubed
zero cubed
zero cubed okay so that was easy so
there's at least one solution and you
might ask
you know are there others i'm going to
write another solution we can write 1 as
10 cubed plus 9 cubed
minus
12 cubed
so people that have seen your taxicab
video might get a bit excited about that
particular one but
let's not go into that here all right so
you've got so there are two ways to do
this two ways to do this
and in fact
there are infinitely many ways to do
this in this particular case
and it's not hard to write down what's
called a parametric solution so i'm
writing 1 as
1 plus 9 m cubed
all cubed
plus 9
m to the 4
all cubed
plus minus 9 m to the 4 minus 3
and the point of this is that this is
valid for any m yes so in the first case
if i put in m equal to zero
i get one
zero
if i put m equal to 1 i get 10
and minus 12. but you could put anything
in and you just get tons and tons of
solutions so yeah in the list that i
started with one is a bit special in
that in fact it's
there there's this parametric family of
solutions and there are infinitely many
different ways of writing one as a sum
of three cubes there are relatively few
examples where we actually have these
parametric solutions and if we go back
to one of the examples we saw before so
for example this number 30
it's suspected that there are not
parametric solutions
although in fact it is suspected that
there are infinitely many solutions
but
they just get big very very quickly and
so as you
measure their density there are very few
solutions overall the whole point about
a parametric solution is that there is a
formula for the solutions you can just
plug in numbers and it will give you
it'll give you some answers that's not
the case for these other examples or
it's suspected to not be the case for
these other examples you have to work
quite hard to find them
it is
12 cubed
plus
1 cubed
or you can write it as 10 cubed
plus 9 cubed equals one seven two nine